matter the outcome there will be at
least three new faces joining the board
8 news now reporter kristen drummond is
in our 80s
newsroom she spoke with the presumptive
winners today kristen
well brian most are hesitant to declare
themselves the winner
yet they want to wait until all the
votes are counted to make it official
so when it is and if these results stay
the same it will
once again be all women on the board
this will definitely revamp the board as
the three
current trustees in districts a b and c
term out
likely filling the seats are lisa guzman
katie williams and evelyn garcia morales
they're being elected during a very
uncertain time as the district navigates
the pandemics economic as well as
academic fallout an issue the women seem
ready to address now but
approach differently when it comes to
students and staff returning to the
classroom
i'm just looking at the southern nevada
health district and if you look at those
numbers
you would say absolutely not by january
these schools need to be open no matter
what i
personally i'd like them to be open on
monday there is a lot of uncertainty
when it comes to reopening
schools right now especially without a
lot of information and a lot of data
the current board will vote on a hybrid
model next week
that's when students attend school a
couple days in person while continuing
distance education
the new board members will not be part
of that decision
they'll be sworn in this january and
then begin their duties so
trustee lola brooks attended a ccsd
board training meeting
and was unavailable for an interview
today but the district e incumbent says
she's happy with the preliminary results
and support during the election
she also hopes to continue representing
district e and students as well as
families
back to you